la tenue de paléontologues du professeur
vente clichés ou réalité est là c'est le
moment de parler c'est le moment de
parler mode chez les paléontologues
donc je vous parle en direct du caroux
on est sur le terrain en ce moment même
envoyé un magnifique affleurements
derrière moi possiblement du trias pour
l'interrogation on sait pas exactement
si on est dans le permis a1 dans le
trias ou sur la limite permise trias
c'est le but de notre de notre fils
tripp de déterminer exactement où on se
trouve dans la stratigraphie il ya une
bonne chance qu'on soit sûr limite
permise trias c'est ce qui nous
intéresse mais trêve de bavardages la
tenue du professeur grant alors est ce
que c'est un cliché d'être habillé comme
le professeur gantt quand on n'est pas
allé en taule og dans un sens oui
puisque quand on se déguise en paillant
autolog c'est comme ça qu'on s'habille
mais sur la réalité du terrain en fait
état est assez proche de ce que la tenue
du professeur quand tu suggères
donc ici on est dans le karoo c'est un
désert aride
un peu comme le montana donc c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui nous intéresse dans
les déserts c'est pour ça que les
paléontologues fouillent toujours dans
les déserts ça vous voyez il ya
quasiment pas de végétation qui recouvre
les affleurements bon celui-là en plus
il est raide alors ça aide un peu mais
voilà il n'y a pas de végétation donc
c'est pour ça que les paléontologues
aime beaucoup les déserts il n'y a pas à
creuser très profond pour trouver les
fossiles donc généralement les
paléontologues fouilles dans les déserts
et comment ça se passe dans les déserts
bas le soleil tape très fort et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut porter quelque chose
sur la tête pour éviter les insolations
maintenant pourquoi le chapeau de cowboy
et bien le chapeau de cow boy il
al'avantage de vous protéger la tête
tout autour voyez et tous ceux qui ont
pris des coups de soleil sur la nuque ou
sur les oreilles comprennent pourquoi il
faut mettre un chapeau de cowboy parce
que le chapeau de cow boy c'est le seul
type de chapeau qui vous protège
absolument tout et il est beaucoup plus
long qu'un bob fallait les bords sont
beaucoup plus long qu'un bob ce qui le
rend ce qui permet de protéger beaucoup
plus vous voyez que je devais absolument
là le soleil est à midi à peu près et
vous voyez que absolument aucun morceau
de peau sur ma tête sur ma nuque net au
soleil dont claque le soleil est haut
plus fort et bien je ne crains
absolument rien oui j'ai
j'ai même pas mis de crème solaire sur
mon front on prenait juste omis un peu
sur le nez la bouche pour ce matin quand
le soleil était rasant mais sinon voilà
au moins ça vous protège physiquement de
la plupart des agressions du soleil
ensuite l'autre l'autre truc des
paléontologues dont c'est pour ça que
les paléontologues porte un chapeau de
cowboy c'est pas juste pour faire cool
d'ailleurs moi j'ai pas l'air cool du
tout dans mon chapeau de cow-boy voyez
c'est pas juste pour avoir l'air cool
c'est surtout parce que le chapeau de
cow boy c'est redoutablement efficace
contre le contre le soleil et
particulièrement dans le désert je me
tourne un peu parce qu'il ya pas mal de
vent et vous allez voir que ça a son
importance le vent ensuite les lunettes
de soleil alors le professeur grant dans
le film fouilles sur un site qui est
déjà connu et donc ils restent sur place
ils ont un campement et ils restent sur
place ils ont de l'équipement etc
donc quand on sait déjà où les fossiles
se trouvait convient pour les déterrer
on peut se permettre d'avoir des
lunettes de soleil d'autant que quand on
creuse quand on va piocher les petits
giclures de petites giclures de roche
qui se projette quand vous piochez vont
rebondir sur les lunettes donc les
lunettes vous protéger les yeux donc les
lunettes de soleil c'est une bonne idée
pour le type de fouille que le
professeur grande pratique pour le type
de fouille que nous pratiquons ici dans
le karoo c'est à dire de la prospection
de surface quand on sait pas encore où
sont les fossiles et ben c'est là par
contre c'est pas une très bonne idée
parce que on a du mal à voir les
contrastes avec les lunettes de soleil
il y en a qui arrivent mais tout le
monde n'y arrive pas moi par exemple j'y
arrive pas donc c'est pour ça que je
porte mes lunettes de vue le net de vue
qui j'aimerais bien me protège un peu
moins des éclats de cailloux parce que à
chaque fois je finis avec des éclats sur
mes lunettes de vue c'est vraiment pas
pratique donc les lunettes de soleil
c'est plutôt une bonne idée dans le
contexte où le professeur grandes
fouilles dans le film le foulard donc le
professeur grant opte pour un foulard un
bandana
moi personnellement j'ai un tour de cou
c'est à dire du stretch c'est en matière
élastique enfin en fibres élastiques
la philosophie est la même deux
fonctions principales
je vais même dire trois fonctions
principales la première protéger la
nuque
toujours au cas où le soleil est rasant
au tour de cou vous protège la nuque
deuxième fonction vous protéger le petit
v là de la chemise voyez quand vous vous
tenez pas votre chemise jusqu'en haut
vous avez un petit becquet ouvert là et
ça c'est pareil si le soleil est un peu
bas vous allez prendre un énorme coup de
soleil en forme de triangle ici une
deuxième fonction protéger ce petit v
que votre chemise laisse derrière elle
et troisième fonction ça c'est alors
c'est pas que pour le kevin 19
c'est pas que pour le convive 19
d'autant que les bords d'un en stretch
comme ça ça a été prouvé que c'est pas
très très efficace contre les postillons
vous pouvez très facilement postillonner
au travers mais par contre par contre ça
protège physiquement et du soleil quand
le soleil est rasant particulièrement
comme moi ce matin quand le soleil était
rasant il me tapait dans le nez donc
vous mettez le bandana et ça vous
protège physiquement le nez et ça vous
protège aussi du vent donc je sais pas
si vous entendez mais ça souffle pas mal
derrière vous pouvez voir les brins
d'herbe qui se couvrent je me suis mis à
l'abri dans un affleurement mais pouvait
voir les brins d'herbe qui secoue
derrière moi donc le ça protège du vent
et quand le vent est sec et chargée de
poussière comme c'est souvent le cas
dans les déserts et ben ça vous tient
les muqueuses non seulement à l'humidité
ce qui vous évite de pisser puis c'est
le sang par le nez au bout de trois
jours mais ça va aussi bas et vous
évitez les gerçures sur les lèvres parce
que très vite
vous allez avoir développé des gerçures
autour des lèvres si vous portez pas de
bandanas donc sa garde l'humidité ça
protège du vent ça protège de la
poussière aussi
donc voilà les toutes les agressions
physiques qui pourraient vous flinguer
vos muqueuses
donc très très très pratique et puis le
soir rêve ou le remonter quand le soleil
devient rasant le soir vous le remonter
savoure protège la nuit donc c'est pas
non plus un cliché le bandana le bandana
c'est très très très très utile ensuite
le professeur grand opte pour une
chemise à carreaux rouges
si je me si je ne m'abuse qui devient
ensuite une chemise bleue quand il va
sur le jurassic park mais sur le terrain
c'est une chemise à carreaux rouges
alors chemise à carreaux rouges qui
était un choix très judicieux
pas seulement pour les bûcherons
canadiens mais surtout parce que l'écart
au saas est connu pour éloigner les
mouches et comme vous pouvez voir moi
par contre je suis entouré de mouches
les les mouches sont très abondantes
dans le désert et en particulier vous
être enfin vous êtes en tant que animal
vivant dans le désert une grande source
d'humidité qui sortent d'ailleurs de
votre nez de votre boucher puis dans
votre dos la sueur sous vos bras donc
vous êtes une source d'humidité et dont
les insectes vont raffoler et les petits
insectes piqueurs vont aussi s'en servir
pour vous localiser et vous sucer le
sang donc la chemise à carreaux elle va
où elle va
repousser un peu les insectes ah oui
d'ailleurs pareil le foulard très
pratique pour empêcher les insectes de
vous rentrez dans les narines
parce que je sais pas si vous avez vu
mais les vaches par exemple elles ont
toujours des insectes dans les narines
c'est parce que l on pas de foulard est
bien là si vous mettez votre foulard ça
évite que les mouches vous rentrer dans
les narines c'est très pénible quand ça
arrive donc c'est très bien d'avoir un
foulard quand c'est comme ça
donc moi je n'ai pas opté pour la
chemise à carreaux rouges parce que je
sais pas ce que je préfère la chemise
blanche unis
chemise blanche unis qui contrairement à
la chemise à carreaux rouges al'avantage
de refléter la totalité de la lumière et
donc ça tient plus au frais ça tient un
peu plus au frais par contre
l'inconvénient de la chemise unie
blanche c'est que si le soleil est
vraiment très très fort
genre si vous êtes en train de fouiller
au milieu de l'été dans le désert le
vous pouvez attraper un coup de soleil
au travers de votre chemise c'est un
problème avec la chemise blanche alors
qu avec du rouge à un peu moins de
chances d'arriver
surtout celle de grant il me semble que
c'est une chemise rouge avec des
carreaux des carreaux un peu plus foncée
donc ça aura sa absorbera un peu plus de
rayons du soleil que la chemise blanche
la chemise pourquoi la chemise et par un
t-shirt le col vous pouvez remonter
votre colle vous protéger pour votre
nuque
aussi la chemise à manches longues l
important la chemise à manches longues
pour protéger vos bras du soleil pareil
pour le pantalon pantalons longs pas de
shorts
enfin un mode en tout cas je ne mets pas
de short dans le désert et le professeur
grant ne met pas non plus de short dans
le désert d'une pour se protéger les
mollets des coups de soleil
parce que pareil vous n'avez peut-être
jamais pris de coup de soleil sur les
mollets mais ça fait mal pour se
protéger les avant bras du soleil est
aussi un truc que j'ai remarqué donc ça
ses expériences personnelles
quand je mets à short et quand je mets
un des tee-shirts
je consomme deux fois plus d'eau donc en
fait avec le vent ma peau évapore
beaucoup plus d'eau et de fait je je je
dois transporter beaucoup plus de
bouteille d'eau avec moi c'est très
c'est un forfait inconvénient quand vous
devez faire plusieurs kilomètres de
prospection dans le désert de
transporter 4 litres d'eau au lieu de 2
ou 6 litres d'eau au lieu de 3 parce
qu'il ya certaines personnes qui ont
besoin de plus d'eau que d'autres le
vent est un petit peu fort je sais pas
si vous l'entendez mais le vent est un
petit peu fort et donc ensuite
professeur grant short en jean
moi je ne pas pas un jean je porte un
pantalon l'entrée ni avec des grandes
poches alors je préfère le truc avec les
grandes poches reei parce que vous
pouvez y mettre plein de choses votre
gps votre boussole crayons cahiers les
fossiles que vous pouvez ramasser une
fois de temps en temps enfin bref c'est
plutôt pratique d'avoir un pantalon avec
des grandes poches qu'un pantalon qu'un
pantalon jean pas ce que le jeans les
poches en plus souvent les jeans et
serré donc vous pourrez rien mettre dans
vos poches donc là par contre je ne suis
pas le professeur quand dans son choix
de pantalon ceci étant dit comme le
professeur groupe ne prospecte pas il a
tout sur place
encore une fois il est il est sur un
site qui a pas besoin où il n'y a pas
besoin de prospecter donc lui il a il a
tout sur place il a tout son équipement
il ya pas besoin d'eux
de s'embêter avec ça donc le choix du
gin est légèrement justifiée quand même
pour pour le type de fouille qui le
pratique est évidemment le plus
important c'est les chaussures grosses
chaussures de randonnée pour pouvoir
marcher très loin pendant très longtemps
et pour protéger les pieds derrière la
protection quand vous voyez c'est
important c'est aussi pour ça qu'ils
font un pantalon c'est pour vous
protéger les genoux quand vous êtes
agenouillé et vous prenez des grosses
chaussures pour pas qu'il y ait de gros
truc pour que s'il ya un gros truc qui
vous tombe sur les pieds ça vous écrase
pas les orteils donc voilà la tenue du
professeur grande finalement c'est pas
tant à clichés que ça la plupart des
éléments de la tenue du professeur
grandes sont tout à fait justifiées
alors c'est peut-être justifiée par dans
le film enfin dans le choix du de la
tenue du film parce qu'ils ont copié la
tenue du professeur grande sur la tenue
de jack corner que jack horner porte sur
le terrain évidemment jack horner et ben
il a toute cette expérience qui lui a
montré que c'était la bonne tenue à
avoir voilà je vous remercie et à très
bientôt